my next-door neighbor and his wife seems  set on becoming friends with me and my  girlfriend they're nice but their  enthusiasm is a little off-putting  is there a polite way we can say we're  not really looking to make friends now  without coming across as dicks  oh that's the worst no probably not a  polite way but the best thing you could  do is just tell them you don't get to  spend a lot of time together so you want  your your quality time together you  don't have time for other people if you  say we're not really looking to make  friends now you will come across it Dex  just DDI I again don't do it idiot don't  make friends with your neighbors